[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute stehen wir hier in unserer Küche
>> MURAT: Im Kindergarten.
>> SALLY: im Kindergarten.
Und zwar gibt es heute ein richtig schönes Projekt.
Denn wir werden die Kindergartenküche
im Kindergarten Don Bosco in Waghäusel erneuern.
Man muss dazu sagen,
den Kindergarten gibt es schon wirklich seit über 40 Jahren,
ich glaube, fast 50.
Ich selber war hier auch drauf
und im Kindergarten.
Und teilweise sind sogar noch meine Erzieher hier.
Und wir haben ja letztes Jahr
schon eine schöne Aktion gemacht
und haben Küchenmaschinen, Küchengeräte gesponsert
und haben dann gesehen, okay,
der Kindergarten ist schon
ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: also wirklich in die Jahre.
Ich war hier als dreijähriges Kind
und genau so, wie ich es hier in Erinnerung hatte,
ist es im Prinzip geblieben.
Und jetzt, haben wir uns gedacht,
machen wir hier die Küche neu,
machen einfach eine schöne Küche,
in der die Erzieherinnen mit den Kindern
hier kochen und backen können
oder eben auch mal in ihrer Mittagspause hier
den Mittag verbringen können.
>> MURAT: Eine komplett neue Küche machen
mit den neuesten Geräten
und allem Drum und Dran.
Weil das ist es einfach wert.
Unsere Stiftung
macht ja alles für Kindererziehung,
Eltern und
>> SALLY: Und für Bildung.
>> MURAT: für Bildung.
Und da ist natürlich ein Kindergarten was Geniales.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Natürlich auch, weil du jetzt
auch in dem Kindergarten selber warst.
>> SALLY: Ja. Man muss ja auch sagen,
gerade im Kindergarten oder in der Schule
finde ich die Kücheneinrichtung eigentlich fast am wichtigsten.
Denn dort sind die Erzieher,
dort sind Lehrkräfte,
die einfach mit den Kindern vieles auch lernen können
und lehren können.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und wenn ich mir jetzt hier
die Kindergartenküche anschaue...
Gut, die Spülmaschine war jetzt wahrscheinlich
– wurde schon ausgebaut.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt gerade so eine Herdplatte wie hier.
Man muss halt auch auf die Sicherheit achten.
Und wenn ich jetzt gerade mir überlege,
wenn ich jetzt an Samira und Ela, an unsere Kinder denke
und ich hätte jetzt noch diese Kochplatte zu Hause,
ist es für mich als Mama
halt ein zu großer Risikofaktor und eine Gefahrenquelle,
weil diese Herdplatten natürlich auch extrem heiß werden.
Das heißt, ich hätte einfach immer die Angst,
dass sie irgendwie doch mit der Hand
auf die heiße Herdplatte langen.
Und das ist halt echt eigentlich schon ein großes Problem.
Und deswegen haben uns gedacht,
zum einen muss es von der Sicherheit her
– und das haben eben alle neuen Küchengeräte,
dass sie auch teilweise wirklich alle kindersicher sind
und man sagt, es gibt eine Kindersperre,
es gibt eine Tastensperre
und da kann einfach nichts passieren.
Und zum anderen muss es halt auch
funktional sein und schön.
>> MURAT: Und neulich sind wir reingelaufen
und die Erzieherinnen haben für die Kinder
Plätzchen gebacken.
Also diese Küche ist nicht nur für die Kinder,
sondern auch für die Erzieher hier drin,
für die Mädels, die auf die Kids hier aufpassen.
Und da habe ich gesehen,
dass sie hier einen kleinen Tisch hatten,
überall Backbleche.
Und hier ist wirklich kein großer Platz.
Und die Geräte, wie gesagt, sind ins Alter gekommen.
Und das machen wir gerne,
haben wir schon ein paarmal gemacht.
Und jetzt zeigen wir es euch,
wie so ein Projekt aussieht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und der Güni und ich
und der Alex und die ganzen Jungs,
wir werden hier jetzt die ganze Küche rausreißen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Dann kommt der Roberto,
unser italienischer Freund.
Der hat ein Fliesenfachgeschäft,
Alescio Fliesentechnik.
Und der hat gesagt: "Komm, ich helfe euch auch noch dabei."
Das heißt, der Roberto wird den Boden fliesen
und hier noch die Wände, den Küchenspiegel fließen.
Und dann kommt dann die neue Küche rein.
Und dann werden wir natürlich die Erzieher überraschen.
Eine ganz coole Geschichte
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: und auch eine Herzensangelegenheit für uns.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, jetzt geht es erst mal los.
Alles wird rausgerissen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann kommt der Roberto mit seinen Fliesen.
Güni und Alex werden noch streichen.
Und dann geht es eigentlich so langsam, aber sicher
an die Küche.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Da bin ich gespannt.
Rausreißen kann der Güni gut.
Ich hoffe, jetzt kommt er gleich und hilft mir.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich bin mal gespannt, wie es nachher aussieht.
>> MURAT: Und ihr seid dabei.
>> MURAT: Fangen wir an?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Alles klar.
>> SALLY: Los geht's!
>> MURAT: Masken auf und los geht's.
So.
Güni?
>> GÜNTER: Ja?
>> MURAT: Guck mal. Der ist schon wieder weg.
Kannst du mir helfen?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Murat, das sind keine neuen Schränke.
Ich weiß, dass du die von Ikea kennst und die so einrasten.
>> MURAT: Nee, das geht. Pass auf.
>> AUS DEM OFF: Da muss man irgendwie doch schrauben.
>> MURAT: Doch. Siehst du?
Siehst du?
>> SALLY: Oi, oi, oi!
>> MURAT: Ha!
>> SALLY: Aha!
>> AUS DEM OFF: Ich habe gedacht, du musst es festschrauben.
>> SALLY: Brauchst du eine Leiter?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Siehst du?
Hast du gesehen?
Murat, schlaue Mensch.
Güni, nicht so schlaue Mensch.
[Musik]
>> GÜNTER: Der hat wenigstens einen deutschen Pass.
>> MURAT: Was hat der?
Ha- ha- hast du gerade gestottert?
Du lügst!
Wenn du stotterst, dann lügst du.
>> GÜNTER: Soll ich dir mal das...
>> MURAT: Aua!
Güni! Wenn da eine Schraube dran gewesen wäre!
[Musik]
So. Jetzt machen wir gerade den Primer drauf.
Nachdem wir den Primer draufgemacht haben,
tun wir eine Spachtelmasse drauf,
dass es richtig so ausnivelliert,
dass es eine Ebene ist,
dass wir komplett nachher alles
auf eine Ebene flach
fliesen können.
[Musik]
Ja.
Unten wurde jetzt gefliest.
Und nach dem Fliesen tun wir und der Güni,
tun wir jetzt tapezieren,
dass wir morgen streichen können.
Wir haben die teure Erfurt Rauhfaser-Tapete geholt
und machen das. Ja.
Und der Güni ist natürlich
– er kann richtig gut tapezieren.
Du bist sozusagen der Einäugige unter den Blinden.
Und deswegen machen wir das jetzt.
Du hast aber richtig Erfahrung mit Tapezieren.
Also eines muss ich ehrlich sagen:
Ich kenne wenige Menschen,
die so gut tapezieren können wie der Güni.
>> GÜNTER: Ja?
>> MURAT: Er kann nichts, aber tapezieren kann er.
Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Vorhin habe ich ihn gesucht.
Dann haben sie ihn in die Pinguingruppe geholt.
Da habe ich den wieder raus
– ich habe dich wieder ausgelöst, nicht?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und zwar: Wir arbeiten hier gerade.
Es ist gerade Betrieb.
Also die Kinder sind alle hier in den Räumen drin.
Die gucken ab und zu mal bei uns vorbei,
beim Güni und bei mir
und drohen uns schon, die Kinder des Zorns.
Aber wie gesagt, wir machen das.
Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Alles okay.
>> MURAT: Fangen wir an?
Bitte zu Hause nicht nachmachen.
Wenn der jetzt noch
einen Fleischkäsewecken in der Hand hätte,
dann würden wir zusammenkrachen wahrscheinlich.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt kommt der Schwiegervater.
Der hat noch gefehlt.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Hallo!
>> MURAT: Aleyküm selam, Papa.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Aha!
Lauter Spezialisten, ja?
>> MURAT: Lauter Spezialisten, Papa.
>> SALLYS PAPA: So. Ja.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Du machst das echt wie so ein Chirurg, gell?
Güni, du bist wie so ein Chirurg.
>> GÜNTER: Du weißt doch genau, dass du momentan
in einer misslichen Lage bist.
>> MURAT: Warum?
Hör auf jetzt! Hör auf!
>> GÜNTER: Tu doch mal nicht so.
>> MURAT: Hör auf!
Papa, sag was.
Diese...
>> GÜNTER: Was ist denn?
>> MURAT: Diese Mensch nix gute Mensch, Papa.
Diese Mensch mich immer beleidigen.
>> GÜNTER: Was?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Papa, und der hat noch
–  der Güni, der hat den Präsidenten beleidigt.
So.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Auf jeden Fall läuft es.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Schnell! Mich kitzelt es an der Nase. Schnell!
>> GÜNTER: Warte.
>> MURAT: Nein! Hör auf!
Ah, Güni!
>> GÜNTER: Ah, was?
>> MURAT: Mach jetzt!
>> GÜNTER: Ach so.
>> MURAT: Kann es sein, dass du als Kind
mal gegen eine Schleuse geschwommen bist?
Kann das sein?
Papa, diese Mann zum ersten Mal das machen.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Ja?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Weißt du, wie lange das dauert,
bis die aus dem Kopf rausgeeitert ist?
>> MURAT: Papa! Papa, sag was!
[Musik]
Nachdem man so eine Tapete eingestrichen hat,
muss man sie so ungefähr immer vier, fünf Minuten
richtig ziehen lassen, dass das richtig
– sonst gibt es Blasen.
Das hat nichts mit dem Güni,
wenn er einen ziehen lässt, zu tun,
sondern wirklich, man muss sie richtig ziehen lassen.
Habe ich recht, Güni?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
Ich wollte schon immer mal so nah bei dir sein.
Habe ich das schon mal gesagt?
>> GÜNTER: Du...
>> MURAT: Papa, sag was!
So.
Ja. Heute ist Tag drei im Kindergarten.
Und ich bin seit drei Tagen
in diesen sieben Quadratmetern gefangen
mit dem Güni zusammen.
Ja.
Ich trage eine Maske,
Güni nicht.
Weil ich habe gehört, dass Dummheit ansteckend ist.
Deswegen habe ich eine Maske an.
Und wir streichen jetzt alles
und morgen soll ja die Küche kommen,
dass wir die Küche dann einbauen können.
Wie gesagt, jetzt werden gerade überall
noch die Steckdosen gemacht.
Die Decke ist jetzt schon gestrichen.
Jetzt werden wir die ganzen Wände noch streichen,
das man nachher diese Übergänge nicht mehr sieht.
Und wir nehmen so einen leichten Grauton,
so ein bisschen was Neutrales.
Weil die Kinder werden nachher sowieso
die ganzen Wände mit irgendwas beklebt,
mit irgendwelchen Bildern, die sie selber gemacht haben.
Ja. Und wie gesagt,
heute komplett streichen,
dass morgen die Küche eingebaut werden kann.
Ja.
[Musik]
So, Güni?
So zickzack?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja?
Güni, so, ja?
>> GÜNTER: Du warst doch mal
ein türkischer Landstreicher, oder?
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So.
Das sind jetzt der Max und der Manuel vom Küchenverband.
Die zwei sind zwei junge
krasse Handwerker und Küchenbauer.
Seid ihr doch, oder, Jungs?
>> MAX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay, euch kann man vertrauen.
>> MAX: Kann man.
>> MURAT: Okay, cool.
So. Mit diesen zwei Jungs
werden wir jetzt die Küche aufbauen.
Die sind vom KüchenTreff-Verband
und haben eine Nobilia-Küche dabei.
Und jetzt machen wir uns an die Arbeit.
Wir werden ungefähr einen ganzen Tag dazu brauchen?
>> MAX: Genau.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und wie viel Material die dabeihaben,
das sehen wir jetzt gleich.
Habt ihr eure Masken dabei?
>> MANUEL & MAX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Perfekt.
Also dann gehen wir rein und fangen mal an.
Ja, und wie gesagt,
hier sind wir jetzt den ganzen Tag dran.
>> MURAT: Richtig?
>> MANUEL & MAX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
das machen der Max und der Manuel wirklich.
Weil die sind die Vollprofis.
Ich glaube, ich würde hier was kaputt machen.
Die Jungs haben gerade richtig viel Arbeit.
Bei euch läuft es übelst, oder? Momentan.
>> MAX: Genau, richtig.
>> MURAT: Die Leute bauen Küchen,
es ist der Wahnsinn momentan.
Und schön, dass die jetzt uns dabei helfen,
das hier zu machen.
Wir bauen das jetzt auf.
Und heute ist Freitag
und wir werden die Erzieherinnen hier im Kindergarten
dann am Montag mit der vollständigen Küche überraschen.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall, wir geben jetzt Gas.
>> MAX: Genau.
>> MURAT: Ich hole euch für nachher schon mal Pizza
für die Mittagspause.
>> MANUEL: Danke.
>> MURAT: Und wir legen dann los, okay?
>> MANUEL & MAX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Alles klar.
[Musik]
Ja, jetzt haben wir ein kleines Problem.
Jetzt versuche ich gerade,
– wir sind hier auf dem Land, das geht jetzt –
einen Freund anzurufen.
Wir müssen das Wasser versetzen,
weil da haben wir was
– da habe ich was falsch ausgemessen.
Und deswegen würde jetzt so eine 60er Spülmaschine
hier nicht reinpassen.
Und jetzt versuchen wir gerade, jemanden zu finden,
der mir noch das Wasser umlegen kann,
ein bisschen zur Seite,
dass eine 60er Spülmaschine reinpasst.
>> CHRISTIAN: Hier.
Hier rüber.
Und hier ein bisschen.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen tricky,
aber wir kriegen das hin.
[Musik]
Das kommt dann morgen wahrscheinlich gleich in der Zeitung:
"Neumann hat Kindergarten Waghäusel
komplett unter Wasser gesetzt.
Bitte am Montag alle Kinder
mit einer Badehose in den Kindergarten schicken."
>> SALLY: Ein paar Arbeitstage später
ist die Küche jetzt endlich fertig.
Und an der Stelle muss ich mich auch
beim KüchenTreff ganz herzlich bedanken.
Denn der KüchenTreff hat hier die Küche gesponsert.
Wir haben dann noch ein paar Partner von uns
mit reingenommen, wie zum Beispiel Bosch.
Bosch hat unsere ganzen Hausgeräte,
Küchengeräte hier gesponsert.
Und mit unserer Stiftung
haben wir die ganze Handwerkerarbeit bezahlt
und haben jetzt auch noch einfach die Küche
– also, weil wir sie eben einrichten wollen,
noch ein bisschen was bestellt,
um praktisch die Küche hier einzurichten.
Beim Küchentreff ist es auch so:
KüchenTreff hat dieses Jahr 25-jähriges Jubiläum
und zu diesem Jubiläum möchten Sie
eine ganz, ganz tolle Aktion starten
jetzt ab dem 1. Februar.
Und zwar verlost der Küchentreff 25 Küchen
im Wert von insgesamt 250.000 Euro.
Und ihr könnt da gerne mitmachen, euch bewerben.
Wenn ihr eine Küche im Kindergarten,
in der Schule, in einer sozialen Einrichtung,
in einem Verein oder in einem Jugendzentrum
zum Beispiel haben möchtet,
dann macht doch einfach ein kurzes Bewerbungsvideo,
so, wie wir das hier sozusagen hatten,
so ein Vorher-Video:
Wie sieht es bei euch in der Einrichtung aus?
Warum möchtet ihr unbedingt eine Küche?
Was wollt ihr damit machen?
Ihr könnt das Ganze dann beim KüchenTreff einreichen
und dann wird das Ganze eben ausgelost.
Und diese 25 Küchen ziehen dann
vielleicht bei euch in der Nähe in der Einrichtung ein.
Wie gesagt, haben wir jetzt hier die Küche fertig.
Jetzt sieht sie noch ein bisschen nackt und leer aus.
Deswegen hole ich jetzt schnell mit dem Murat die Kartons
und wir richten die Küche schön ein.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt haben wir hier noch
Kinderschürzen ohne Ende.
Kinderschürzen.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Dann haben wir jetzt hier noch
drei prall gefüllte Taschen.
Und zwar hat unser Freund Norbert aus Hockenheim
unsere Storys gesehen, dass wir hier die Küche einrichten,
und hat gesagt: "Mensch, Sally, ich sponsere auch."
Der Norbert ist nämlich sozusagen
der Daniel Düsentrieb der Küchenbranche.
Er ist Entwickler.
Und er hat zum Beispiel die Kochblume
entwickelt.
Er hat diese ganzen Zubehörteile,
die ganzen Silikon-Kitchen-Tools,
die ich auch immer benutze.
Und die hat er uns jetzt noch gesponsert,
dass ich die Küche damit einrichten kann.
Also ich habe jetzt hier erst mal, glaube ich,
grob alles ausgepackt.
Und jetzt räume ich alles dahin, wo es gebraucht wird.
Ich würde sagen, Silikonkochbesteck
direkt zum Herd, also in die Schublade.
[Musik]
Silikon ist ja lebensmittelecht,
ist geruchs- und geschmacksneutral,
ist hitzebeständig bis über 300°C,
kann in die Spülmaschine,
zerkratzt keine Töpfe, keine Pfannen
und es ist wirklich so, dass es einfach sauber ist,
hygienisch ist.
Und jetzt gerade hier in der Küche mit Kindern
finde ich das schon wichtig.
>> MURAT: Mach du das, okay?
>> SALLY: Danke.
>> MURAT: Mach du das einfach.
Das ist dann besser.
Ich kümmere mich dann einfach nur
– soll ich was sauber machen?
>> SALLY: Nee, aber du kannst...
Ich mache das kurz.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]
Also fangen wir mal im Uhrzeigersinn an.
Hier direkt am Eingang
– man muss ja wissen, vorher war ja wirklich
nur da vorne die Küche bestückt sozusagen
und hier war alles ein bisschen toter Raum.
Jetzt haben wir hier direkt am Eingang
auch einen Hochschrank.
Da ist eine Mikrowelle drin verbaut.
Da können sich die Erzieher
auch ihr Essen mal warm machen.
Hier oben ganz viel Stauraum.
Ich habe jetzt hier mal einfach die Ofenbleche reingelegt.
Aber da hätten sie auch im Prinzip Stauraum
für Vorräte zum Beispiel, wie Kaffee oder Milch oder Zutaten.
Wie gesagt, hier eine Mikrowelle,
die auch echt ganz schick aussieht.
Dann einen Kühlschrank,
der von der Größe her echt auch ganz gut
für so einen Kindergarten geeignet ist,
weil der auch nicht so groß ist.
Also hier sind nicht zu viele Kinder.
Und da unten ist so ein kleines Fach unter dem Kühlschrank,
was wahrscheinlich viele von euch haben.
Und da könnt ihr entweder Küchenrolle verstauen
oder zum Beispiel Einkaufstüten,
also so flache Dinge,
oder auch Backofenbleche.
Also da könnt ihr wirklich jeden Platz sehr gut ausnutzen.
Dann haben wir jetzt hier einfach mal
die zwei Küchengeräte platziert,
die Kaffeemaschine, wo man eben auch täglich dran muss,
hier die Küchenmaschine.
Und, damit es eben auch gut passt,
so praktisch die Tassen direkt zur Kaffeemaschine.
Hier stelle ich gleich noch den Kaffee dazu.
Und hier ist ja auch noch ordentlich Platz.
Also ich habe es jetzt auch nicht randvoll gemacht.
Denn die Erzieher haben mit Sicherheit auch noch
ihr ganzes Zubehör, was in der alten Küche mit drin war.
Dann haben wir hier direkt am Herd
– und das ist auch ganz wichtig,
gerade hier in so einer Einrichtung.
Und zwar gibt es hier eine Sicherung.
Das ist praktisch, dass die Geräte erst dann funktionieren,
wenn die Erzieher praktisch die Sicherung reinmachen,
damit das eben auch ein Kinderschutz ist.
Man hat zwar hier auch ein bisschen
einen doppelten Kinderschutz,
weil die Kinder ja erst mal den Knopf drücken müssten,
um dann hier zu drehen,
aber so kann man einfach noch sichergehen,
dass da kein Kind was anschaltet,
was eben jetzt nicht unter Aufsicht ist vielleicht.
Hier ist auch ein Hochschrank.
Und da haben wir jetzt
zwar die ganzen Küchentücher reingelegt,
aber da oben wäre jetzt auch noch Platz
zum Beispiel für Reinigungsmittel.
Da kommen ja Kinder auch nicht dran.
Hier habe ich jetzt den Power Plus Blender platziert.
Denn Murat holt jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen Obst.
Dann können wir hier Obst reinlegen.
Und dann können sie auch leckere Smoothies
und Ingwer-Shots zum Beispiel machen.
Ja, und auch hier auf der Rückseite
haben wir eigentlich Schubladen,
weil ich finde, dass in Schubladen
alles ein bisschen ordentlicher aussieht.
Und man hat einfach so den Überblick.
Hier das ganze Besteck,
Kuchentester
und Ausstecher.
Man kann ja damit noch Plätzchen und Kekse backen
oder auch mal für Knete benutzen.
Hier noch das Backzubehör.
Ich lasse aber das meiste erst mal noch eingepackt.
Denn dann können sie auch noch mal nachlesen,
was wofür war.
Und hier unten ein ganzes Fach
mit Küchenschürzen für Kinder und für Erwachsene.
Und was wir hier auch ganz schön haben:
einfach direkt einen Tisch mit dabei,
dass man hier dran arbeiten kann
und sich auch mal dran setzen kann.
Ja.
Jetzt warten wir noch auf Obst und Gemüse von Murat.
Und dann sind wir fertig.
Jetzt haben wir die Küche fertig eingerichtet.
Und ihr seht es schon,
wir sind momentan immer noch in der Pandemie-Situation.
Aber jetzt darf ich der Frau Schulreich
– sie ist mittlerweile die Kindergartenleitung, gell? –
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Ja.
>> SALLY: die Küche übergeben.
Ja, ich hoffe, die gefällt euch.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Das ist aber supergut.
Also wir sind total begeistert.
>> SALLY: Das freut mich.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Also ja,
es ist wirklich sehr gelungen geworden.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir haben jetzt im Prinzip
auch alles Mögliche eingerichtet.
Also Gläser haben wir jetzt hier.
Und Kaffeetassen haben wir hier.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Schön!
>> SALLY: Da haben wir jetzt alles aus Emaille gewählt,
weil das auch sicherer für die Kinder dann ist.
Wir haben überall noch die Verpackung teilweise dran,
damit ihr wisst, wie ihr es gebraucht.
Ich habe nur noch keine Edelstahltöpfe.
Deswegen ist das Fach hier noch leer.
Wir haben nur die Gusseisentöpfe und ich glaube,
die wären ein bisschen zu schwer wahrscheinlich.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Hm. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, hier haben wir so einen Überkochschutz
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Ach, wie schön!
>> SALLY: und Kochbesteck,
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Super!
>> SALLY: alles aus Silikon.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Hach, was da alles rauskommt!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und wir haben so ganz kindersicher
die Messer mal hier oben gelagert,
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Ja, sehr gut. Ja.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Das ist auch wichtig. Ja.
>> SALLY: dass die hier oben sind.
>> SALLY: Und auf der Rückseite hier
dann Küchenschürzen für alle.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Ach Mensch!
Klasse!
>> SALLY: So für Klein und Groß.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Ach was? Schön!
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen Backzubehör noch.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Super!
>> SALLY: Und Besteck hier.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Super! Echt!
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Also perfekt!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Da könnt ihr ja dann mal durchschauen.
Und wenn es Fragen gibt, einfach melden.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gell?
Okay.
Ja, im Prinzip ist unser Video jetzt auch zu Ende.
Also wir haben jetzt hier die Kindergartenküche fertiggestellt,
erfolgreich übergeben.
>> FRAU SCHULREICH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich denke, dass ihr hier mit den Kindern
wahrscheinlich viele, viele schöne Dinge machen werdet.
Ihr leistet ja auch gerade
– also jeder in Bildungseinrichtungen
leistet auch gerade viel, viel, viel Arbeit
in der besonderen Situation.
Und falls ihr auch solche Projekte unterstützen wollt,
dann könnt ihr gerne mal auf sallys-stiftung.de gehen.
Denn da sind wir auch wirklich aktiv.
Und das ist eine Stiftung,
da verdient wirklich keiner einen Cent daran.
Das geht wirklich alles
– alle, die da mitwirken, sind ehrenamtlich tätig
und verdienen da nichts daran.
Die machen das alle aus Leidenschaft und helfen uns da mit.
Falls ihr ein Projekt habt,
dann könnt ihr uns auch gerne schreiben.
Und vielen Dank auch noch mal an den KüchenTreff,
der die Küche gesponsert hat.
Vielen Dank an unsere Partner
wie Bosch, wie Nobilia oder auch Kochblume,
die uns die Geräte gesponsert haben und die Einrichtung.
Und ja, wenn ihr weitere Infos wollt,
dann geht noch mal auf kuechentreff.de.
Denn dieses Jahr werden noch mal 25 Küchen gestiftet
im Wert von insgesamt 250.000 Euro.
Und ja, das war jetzt eine davon,
die 26. sozusagen als Start.
Und dann wünsche ich euch viel Spaß
beim Kochen und Backen weiterhin.
Tschüss!
>> ERZIEHERIN 1: Wie die Kinder, alles ausprobieren, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ERZIEHERIN 2: Oh! Fantastisch!
Also wir brauchen jetzt für die Basare
nicht mehr Kuchenspenden,
wir können selber backen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ERZIEHERIN 2: Ja, super!
>> ERZIEHERIN 3: Jetzt können wir mittags
endlich Mittagessen warm machen!
Juhu!
>> ERZIEHERIN 1: So. Da weiß man ja bald,
was wir auch privat so kaufen können, gell?
Ich muss mal gucken. Ich bin neugierig.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ERZIEHERIN 1: Das kennen wir ja gar nicht.
>> ERZIEHERIN 3: Oh, wie schön!
[Musik]